public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
michel sapin le ministre de l'économie
et des finances est l'invité de
l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir monsieur le
ministre merci d'être avec nous à ce
rendez vous donc de public sénat avec
les échos radio classique et l' agence
france-presse bien sûr vous allez réagir
dans quelques secondes aux derniers
chiffres du chômage fin septembre il est
bon un fort recul
après cela il y aura trois grandes
questions pour vous est ce que vous
prétendez toujours où plus que jamais ce
soir avoir redressé l'économie vous
répondrez à jean francis pécresse
françois hollande doit-il renonçait à se
présenter en 2017 il n'y a pas que
l'économie il ya également les faits
livre vous le savez vous répondre ils
hallucinent malandain enfin et si la
droite et le centre avaient le remède ou
les remèdes vous évoquerez avec michael
ms la primaire de la droite et du centre
donc mais d'abord bien sûr la question
d'actualité ce soir pour l'emploi vient
de publier les chiffres de septembre
avec une donc une baisse importante 60
3300 après la très forte hausse et
enregistrement s'en souvient au mois
d'août
c'est un effet de balancier bien sûr que
vous savourez ce soir est ce que vous
avez une explication à ce chiffre
je crois qu'il vaut éviter des
expressions du genre savourer ou être
jovial parce qu'il ya un chiffre qui est
un très bon chiffre
un mois le mois précédent il était de
très bonne qualité était même à linverse
d'ailleurs été saluée si je puis dire
par l'ensemble des commentateurs sur le
thème terrible affreux épouvantable
aujourd'hui je n'emploierai pas des
termes inverses calme en cours un
chiffre qui est de même en déniant
qu'est ce chiffre aux mains parce que
moi je connais bien ces mécanismes de
chiffres mensuels du chômage
j'étais ministre du travail jean connaît
à la fois la pertinence parce que ça
indique des choses et en même temps je
reconnais la volatilité on n'avait pas
couvert action quand je regarde une
chose je regarde une seule chose que
s'est il passé au cours des derniers
mois que s'est il passé par exemple
depuis le début de cette année est-ce
que trimestre par trimestre ne prenons
pas mois par mois parce que c'est un six
mois par mois
enfin je devrais dire c'est ainsi mois
par mois
lees qu'au cours de ces trois derniers
trimestres est ce que le chômage a
baissé
c'est le troisième trimestre consécutif
avec les trois derniers mois où le
chômage baisse en france s'est défait je
ne dis pas qu'il faut s'en réjouir ou
qu'il faut s'en satisfaire
définitivement mais les faits c'est que
le chômage a baissé au titre des
chiffres de pôle emploi depuis le début
de cette année est ce que ça va se
poursuivre en ce moment là ce sont juste
pour que les gens aient de charente est
ce que ça reste pour 90 mille chômeurs
de moins depuis le début d'année
on est dans la rejoint cela rejoint un
autre type de chiffres seront toujours
les gens s'ils perdent là dedans qui est
le chiffre international le chiffre des
comparaisons internationales
c'est le chiffre qui étaient établis par
l'insee avec des règles dites du bureau
international du travail
et ces chiffres là qui ont été
d'ailleurs cité dans un débat qui avait
lieu juste avant cette émission sont des
chiffres qui indiquent depuis un an le
chômage baisse en france le pourcentage
de chômeurs par rapport à la population
active ne cesse de baisser depuis alors
ça vaut le dire simplement et le chômage
baisse
clairement en france depuis un an et
venir les chiffres qui viennent
d'arriver confirme cette évolution à la
baisse est ce que c'est l'inversion de
la courbe annoncé si je devais reprendre
cette expression qui maintenant est
totalement dévaloriser puisqu'elle a été
utilisée réutiliser au commentaire
critique et la vérité c'est que quand le
chômage baisse depuis un an ça doit
s'appeler une courbe inversée du chômage
mais laissons cela de côté
je pense que pour les français c'est
presque plus compréhensible ainsi et
c'est comme ça je l'espère que pour ceux
qui retrouvent de l'emploi ils le vivent
le chômage baisse en france depuis un an
c'est clair net et précis et toutes les
statistiques vont dans le même sens il
assure un quinquennat sur le quinquennat
il augmentait de combien si je alors je
vous preniez une catégorie les jeunes
parce qu'on est toujours à se préoccuper
à juste titre du chômage des jeunes qui
est plus élevé que le chômage de manière
générale est ce que le nombre des jeunes
aujourd'hui au chômage le nombre des
jeunes aujourd'hui au chômage est
supérieur ou inférieur au nombre des
joueurs au chômage au début de ce
quinquennat rive est donc inférieur il
est inférieur aux aimé qui le dit qui le
commande ce chiffre là qui est
indubitable indubitable
après si vous prenez le nombre global
des chômeurs dans les catégories à
partir du plus âgé il est aujourd'hui
encore plus élevé que donnera au début
de cette formule élevé qu'au début elle
plus élevé qu'au début la population
active a elle même aussi augmenté nous
avons une un pays qui a une
caractéristique est une bonne chose
c'est qu'ils arrivent sur le marché du
travail tous les ans plus de personnes
que ceux qui alors mais non bien sûr
c'est pas le cas en allemagne
c'est pas le cas en espagne ans c'est
pas le faire ibm igraal fig
donc c'est pas bien sûr il ya une
carrière de virilité on sent pays fait
que nous devons en france créé plus
d'emplois qu'ailleurs pour faire
récupérer le crime voilà votre réaction
donc à ce chiffre important du jour la
suite tout de suite de l'épreuve de
vérité avec la question que vient vous
poser jean francis pécresse le directeur
de la rédaction de radio classique
l'épreuve de vérité les crédits
classiques elysiques au bond sera gens
pensaient son sort michel bonsoir michel
sapin alors il y a un bon chiffre du
chômage qui est tombé ce soir mais
au-delà de ce chiffre là il ya le bilan
économique de ce quinquennat croissance
très faible très très faible à peine
plus de 1 1 % en 2016 à peine plus de 1%
en 2010 est peut-être il y à chômage
quand même + 6 600 mille chômeurs de
plus depuis mai 2012
quand nos voisins font beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup mieux
il ya la dette publique 98 5 % de la
richesse il ya le taux de prélèvements
obligatoires qui est un qui est à un
niveau absolument record est ce que vous
espérez convaincre les français que vous
avez redresser l'économie française
tel que présenté par vous y compris avec
les inexactitudes que cela comporte
alors quelques inexactitudes et y
compris des inexactitudes que cela
comporte et sans élément de comparaison
avec ce qui pouvait se passer votre fois
la taille et la masse est dit si je puis
me permettre
la messe est dite la messe est dite tel
que vous le présentez vient donc on va
essayer de reprendre les choses aussi un
peu tels que quelques sons quand on veut
regarder quel est le chemin parcouru par
un gouvernement et par une majorité il
vaut mieux parti de savoir de loups nous
on part et j'espère que vous ne
considérez pas que la france en 2012
était en discussion exceptionnel
si je prenais les chiffres que vous
venez d'avancé qu'ils sont des chiffres
pour certains d'entre eux exact pour
d'autres contestables
est ce que le déficit public en france
en 2012 était supérieur à celui
d'aujourd'hui ou pas il était super et
largement supérieur
il a donc diminué vous est-ce que la
dette 2012 le ramener à 3% du pib en
est-ce que la dette la dette qui était à
86% des pieds de la valeur de 5 ans vous
l'avez augmenté de 4,5 milliards d'euros
entre en l'espace de cinq ans de vous
n'avez donc on aimerait que crise et
comment il fallait repenser à présenter
les choses si tout de suite je m'y
attendais c'est plutôt à lodève ou
internats manière vous avez présenté les
choses dépendront les auditeurs de radio
classique
elles sont donc lag la dette avait
explosé de 25 points de pib entre 2007
et 2012
elle a augmenté de 7 points de pib entre
2012 et aujourd'hui c'est peut-être trop
vous pouvez me fait cette critique vient
c'est trop s'en crée ce qu'elle est
stabilisé oui elle est aujourd'hui
stabilisé aux alentours de 96 80 18 les
derniers chiffres et que vous le savez
pas ce que vous êtes un bon spécialiste
à drogba sera d'ici à la fin de cette
année elle sera aux alentours de 96 % du
pipe donc nous avons stabilisé la dette
est ce que nous avons parce que notre
économie mais c'est pas nous c'est des
entreprises mais on crée quand même une
ambiance on crée aussi des outils qui
leur permettent de faire cela parce que
les entreprises ont recommencé à créer
des emplois privés
je parle pas de ce qui peut se passer
dans les formations je ne passe pas de
sortir du rhdp dans des bons 140001
défieurs donc bien entendu ceci ça
suffit à faire reculer le chômage
on le voit mais est-ce que ça suffit à
ce que dans la durée on puisse
considérer que la france a retrouvé une
situation de manière qui nous dit
parfaitement cette distance évidemment
dans la question ils sont et ce à la
question finale
donc depuis quand n'avait-on pas créer
140 mille emplois en un an
bon depuis des années et des années il
faut remonter avant la crise 2007
bref je prends ces chiffres là pourquoi
elle comporte aussi la satisfaction si
la situation d'aujourd'hui ne peut pas
être considérée comme satisfaisante
vous pouvez pas de satisfaits
définitivement d'une situation où il ya
encore autant de chômeurs vous ne pouvez
pas être satisfait d'une situation où
nous avons certes fait reculer le
déficit de la france derrière le déficit
et la dette moi c'est la seule chose qui
me
et la dette c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut rembourser c'est quelque chose qui
pèse soient les générations ça pèse sur
vos enfants sur les miens et sur mes
petits-enfants ou sur les votre nom vous
n'avez pas encore des petits-enfants
bien bref donc donc donc je ne veux pas
de ça donc est-ce que de ce point de vue
là on a amélioré les choses la réponse
est oui
objectivement entraîneur on regarde les
choses alors que ses dires agressée
on peut dire redresser est ce que c'est
on est au bout du chemin non est ce qui
a encore deux des progrès à faire c'est
évident est-ce qu'il ya encore des gens
malheureux en france si on a
considérablement qui sont malheureux en
france est ce qui a encore des choses à
faire pour les entreprises puisque c'est
aussi des sujets qui vous intéressent et
m'intéresse
la réponse est oui nous avons fait le
cic eux nous avons fait ce qu'on appelle
le pacte de responsabilité donc des
baisses de charges
nous avons annulé la totalité des
augmentations de charges voter certes
par cette majorité mais votée par la
majorité précédente
donc si on a fait un chemin absolument
considérable ces dommages ne peut pas
considérer ce chemin même si ça
n'empêche pas d'avoir des critiques par
ailleurs mais c'est bon ça peut partir
d'une base objectifs permet d'avoir un
débat ensuite tenu informé chelsea
l'allemagne sur la même période
exactement de mai 2012 à août 2016 fait
480 mille chômeurs de moins
l'espagne ont fait 1 million 400 mille
et le royaume uni ont fait plus de 6 700
milles de moi qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
marché en france alors juste a aussi
quand on fait des comparaisons c'est
juste il faut le faire pour savoir faire
des campagnes d'entre eux revient sur
l'allemagne ou prenez l'espagne
heureusement que nous sommes pas dans la
situation espagnole en france
aujourd'hui
heureusement la france on l'a d'espagne
ce serait le pays miraculeux
quel est le taux de chômage ils ont fait
chuter les taux de chômage 25 19 le taux
de chômage des jeunes dit il et il est
aux alentours de 50 concerts bref
heureusement d'opale en situation et
comme vous le savez la d'espagne n'a
toujours pas retrouvé aujourd'hui la
richesse le pipe comme on dit que qui
était le sien en 2007 donc j'ai
heureusement que ce n'est pas en espagne
et quand on est tombé très bas c'est
vrai qu'on reprenons l'allemagne parce
que là c'est évidemment comparable
sommes deux grandes économies c'est
beaucoup plus comparable où on était
l'allemagne en 2012 du point de vue de
ses finances publiques parce que les
finances lui que ça compte quand vous
avez des bonnes finances publiques à
l'aise si je puis dire vous pouvez
impulsé vous pouvez soutenir vous pouvez
faire en sorte que ce soit des finances
au service de la croissance ou et et
quel était le déficit de l'allemagne en
ayrault là où nous étions à plus de 5%
de déficit zéro et où on l allemagne
aujourd'hui à zéro ou un peu plus c'est
à dire qu'elle n'a pas eu pendant ces
cinq ans à faire d'efforts budgétaires
elles l'avaient fait avant elle avait
fait avant avant 2012 elle avait refait
ce n'est pas budgétée et donc pendant
toute cette période elle a pu avoir une
politique beaucoup plus comme on dit
dans le jargon des économistes
expansionniste là où alan il a fallu
certaines critiques en disant que
c'était une politique autoritaire c'est
pas vrai ces restes hérité ça c'est ce
qui s'est passé en espagne ou au
portugal
mais nous il a fallu avoir une politique
sérieuse du point de vue budgétaire en
dessous d'or d'augmentation d'impôts ou
45 milliards nomades augmentation de 55
sont les deux cd de côté 1 donc c'est ce
que ce qu'avaient voté nicolas sarkozy
si je puis dire ce qui a été voté depuis
sans compter pas après la politique qui
est la nôtre aujourd'hui qui est plus de
croissance
vous dites à peine 1% quand on est 1,3
pour cent c'était l'année dernière aux
alentours de 1 5% cette année et qu'on
recherche quelque chose qui est
largement supérieur à 1% pour l'année
prochaine on a autour de 1,5 à peine à
recruter tout ça peut être risqué
on a retrouvé la croissance et c'est
cette croissance qui nous permet
aujourd'hui un de baisser les impôts et
charges et les impôts de de faire face
aussi à des dépenses supplémentaires
parce que je me dirais pas que la france
du point de vue de la sécurité est
exactement dans la même situation que
celle de 2012 les attentats terroristes
la situation en syrie ou en irak ce
n'était pas exactement ce que la france
avait en face d'elle on est obligé ça
perd lui aussi y faire face
merci beaucoup jean-francis lucile
malandain de la fp nous rejoint
effectivement vous avez raison michel
sapin on va reparler du livre je m'y
attendais il est prof de vérité
des clichés bonsoir lui c'est bon sens
michel beaucoup de sapins alors françois
hollande doit-il renoncé à se lancer
dans une nouvelle campagne
présidentielle on a vu que les nuages
s'amoncelaient sur son passage récemment
vous qui y est très proche de lui
compenser vous proche ou pas proche ça
change pas grand chose en l'occurrence
on est dans le monde politique dans le
domaine politique
il est président de la république il
assume d'abord et avant tout les tâches
qui sont celles d'un président de la
république et il n'a pas à se laisser
troubler par tel ou tel commentaire par
telle ou telle parution tel ou tel livre
tel ou tel débat autour de la parution
de sony même si ces débats sont par
ailleurs parfaitement lui qui parle pas
on n'a pas se laisser troubler par les
débats ces débats sont parfaitement
légitimes donc et je veux y participer
si vous le souhaitez sur le bouquin oui
mais mais il est présent appli qui doit
assumer pleinement et totalement ses
fonctions il a donné une orientation et
à plusieurs mois de cela en disant je
dirais aux alentours de mi décembre
si je suis candidat ou si je ne suis pas
candidat
rien de ce point de vue là n'a changé
c'est à mi décembre que le président la
république actuel dira s'il a choisi et
pour quelles raisons s'il a choisi
d'être candidat on n'est pas candidat
juste pour le plaisir il bet on est
candidats qu'aux quelque chose à espérer
qu avant la fin de l'année absolument
persuadé que dans le contexte actuel il
espérait que d'un coup il a l'air d'être
retrouvée où trouver parce que vous
regardez aussi les choses dans la durée
des niveaux de popularité et je fais une
grande différence a aussi cette
expérience entre ce qu'on appelle la
popularité est ce qu'on appelle une
intention de vote
c'est pas tout à fait de même nature des
faits de même nature
si je regarde l'intérêt de la gauche
puisque certains je le comprends pense à
l'intérêt de la gauche
l'intérêt de la gauche c'est que
françois hollande soit de nouveau le
candidat parce que c'est celui quelles
que soient les commentaires du jour du
lendemain ou de la veille
c'est celui qui a le plus de capacité à
rassembler la gauche
quelles que soient les critiques quelles
que soient les insatisfactions même si
je regarde si on m'aimait mais les
déceptions sont une chose il faut les
regarder comme tel il faut les analyser
comme tel il faut les respecter comme
tel il faut leur apporter des éléments
d'explication et du monde espoirs il
s'agit pas de dire les français sont
heureux ils demandent qu'une seule chose
non
réalité en face mais moi je compare la
politique c'est pas simplement de
regarder quelqu'un c'est aussi de
comparer aux autres et quand je compare
aux autres candidats de gauche
je n'en vois aucun qui soit mieux placé
que françois hollande pour rassembler au
premier tour et évidemment si c'est le
look
il faut rassembler au 2e manuel valls
qui a beaucoup modifier son discours ces
dernières semaines qui samedi dernier
débat s'est présentée quand même un
homme de rassemblement on va l'écouter
je vais tomber l'art mieux elles valent
sur les prix jouent désormais
effectivement l'uscri vous avez raison
la carte du rassemblement alors moi je
veux que chacun se pose les bonnes
questions
je demande arnaud à benoît aurélie elle
manuel patois l'autre qu'est ce qui nous
sépare
bien sûr je connais le débat mais au
fond qu'est ce qui nous rapproche
d'abord d'avoir gouverné ensemble avec
le président un public et des valeurs
des valeurs celles de la république lui
aussi s'avance au nom du rassemblement
il est même soutenu on l'a compris a
presque reçu l'aval de jean christophe
cambadélis le pad et ne pas trop les
parties et alors et que le national a
parlé d'un problème d'incarnation ce
matin on va s'y prendre les choses dans
l'ombre donc le premier ministre qui est
aujourd'hui soutenue par une majorité de
gauche à l'assemblée nationale
on l'a vu encore avec le dernier vote
sur le parlement il ya une majorité
majorité absolue de vote pour bon il est
soutenu par une majorité de gauche et il
se comporte en rassembleur de la gauche
ce jubilé c'est c'est bien tant mieux
puisqu'il va falloir rassembler et il
est avec la loyauté qu'on lui connaît et
la loyauté qui le décrit avec sincérité
a souhaité que le prix dans la
république puisse être le candidat qui
représente cette gauche donc on est donc
il n'a pas une idée
notre religion la tête moi je vais vous
demander quelle est votre idée derrière
la tête non je vous écoute et j'analyse
que vous ne dites pas ce que vous avez à
présent de sa loyauté en france et qui
cause c'est l'arrière penser à moi je
regarde l'écologie contre la laïcité
l'adoucissant discours mais l'armée mais
c'est moi je ne vais pas m'en plaindre
je vais vous dire les choses très
simplement je préfère largement le
discours là sur le rassemblement qui est
au nom de quoi qui est pas ou non
formelle qui est vous avez participé à
la gestion de la france ceux qui
appartiennent à cette gauche qui est
prête à prendre des responsabilités même
si à un moment donné il peut y avoir des
désaccords vous qui savez que rien ne se
fait en un jour
rien ne se faire en un soir que le coup
du grand soir et le lendemain matin on
se réveille heureux ça n'existe pas
qu'il faut prendre les choses à bras le
corps qu'il faut mettre les mains dans
le cambouis tous ceux là qui ont mis les
mains dans le cambouis
vous vous devez vous rassembler tous'
set mais il a fait flop vient se faire
peloter vous me le passer c'est que sa
basse et flops sinon mettez vous le vous
le présenter comme des comme quelque
chose d'important
donc je préfère je vais jusqu'au bout de
ma phrase de je préfère ce discours de
rassemblement
à un moment donné une phrase peut être à
lui a échappé qui disait il ya deux
gauches irréconciliables pour moi je
pense qu'il ya pas de gauches
irréconciliables
il y à une gauche difficile rassembler
très difficiles à rassembler et dans les
comptes le contexte d'aujourd'hui
extrêmement difficiles à rassembler mais
la gauche peut se rassembler non
seulement ça elle doit se rassembler
elle est aujourd'hui certains ont
utilisé le terme pulvérisé en poussière
parce qu'il ya plein de petits morceaux
partout et la tâche qui est la nôtre
la tâche du président la tâche du
premier ministre c'est de faire en sorte
de cette vision éclatée de la gauche on
ait une vision un peu plus rassembler je
suis pas je sais très bien qu'il restera
des cassures qui restera des
concurrences mais il faut rassembler
cette gauche parce que le seul moyen
pour que les français est un choix
qu'ils soient pas réduits entre la
droite et l'extrême droite c'est de
faire en sorte que la gauche soit
présente au deuxième tour de cette
élection présidentielle ne sera pas
présent vous l'avez dit et c'était le
reflet paraîtra pas présent mais elle
sera pas présente
s'il ya une cassure aussi forte
qu'aujourd'hui vous pariez de loyauté
est
et de rassemblement est ce que la
démarche des manuels macron fait partie
d'une part de la loyauté et d'autre part
du rassemblement est ce que ce n'est pas
dangereux compris pour une candidature
de françois bayrou je pense que tout ça
va revenir dans l'ordre si je puis dire
chacun va enfin c'est qu'il voir
apprécié pouvoir apprécier qu'elle est
là le poids exact des uns et des autres
au delà de la nouveauté au delà
d'intelligence au delà des qualités qui
sont réelles chez tel ou tel et en
particulier chez emmanuel macron moi je
dis pour rassembler la gauche je dis pas
je fais aucune différence entre la
droite et la gauche où je suis nulle
part être nulle part ça peut attirer la
bienveillance pendant quelques semaines
mais il ya un moment donné j'ai employé
l'expression il faut redescendre sur
terre et sur terre en politique en
france il ya une droite et une gauche
qui sont pas séparés surtout il ya bien
des sujets sur lesquels la droite et la
gauche peuvent agir ensemble dans le
domaine chez pas internationale pour
soutien aux armées pour un salon de la
défense assemble de grands principes
républicains par rapport par exemple à
l'extrême droite même s'il ya une partie
de la droite qui est tenté de faire
toujours la course avec l'extrême droite
y compris sur les principes républicains
mais il ya la gauche et la droite et on
a un système électoral les
présidentielles et législatives qui est
un système majoritaire à deux tours avec
un système majoritaire à deux tours
vous avez deux camps et il vaut mieux
appartenir à l'un ou appartenir à
l'autre si on veut plus dernière des
ratures et faire quelque chose pour le
bien des frais que vous pouvez l'arrêter
un maquereau mais c'est pas l'arrêté je
pense que ça mettra tout seul à modérer
chauvel qui s'arrêtera se souvient ira
jusqu'au bout de ce qu'il voudra il
s'agace il ya un moment où dès lors
qu'on rentre dans le domaine des choses
sérieuses où en est la gauche est ce que
la gauche peut bouger ce qu'elle peut
faire face aux difficultés considérables
qu'elles rencontrent aujourd'hui ou non
et quand on se pose cette question là à
ce moment là aller on est revenus sur
terre et on appartient
à l'un ou à l'autre on n'est pas
ailleurs eh bien ça réellement ballon
qui cale je sais pas s'il faut dire cela
j'en sais rien la loyauté
il avait cette qualité existait il en
aurait fait preuve plus tôt mais non
mais parce qu'il ya des forces
politiques à des rapports de force
il ya des réalités et les réalités
finissent par s'imposer alors le style
lui rappeler que vous êtes un ami très
ancien de françois hollande et certains
de ses amis aujourd'hui comme l'avocat
jean pierre mignard lui dit notamment
lui mais il y en a d'autres
ségolène royal n'y va pas en 2017 tu va
subir une humiliation vovo lui dit vas-y
au risque d'une humiliation mais la
décision
elle n'est pas prise par un ami aussi
intime soit il je dirais même il vaut
mieux pas être un ami hatim pour vous
conseiller quelque chose dans ce cas là
parce qu'on prend en considération
d'autres éléments que les éléments à
caractère politique et de ce qu'est ce
qui peut être bon pour la gauche qui
n'est pas un sujet quand on est de
gauche mais qu'est ce qui peut être bon
pour la france qui est un sujet
fondamental quand on est français ce qui
est notre cas
donc moi je ne suis pas un ami qui donne
des conseils d'amis d'accord je fais une
analyse politique et ola 10 politique
elle me fait dire aujourd'hui que
françois hollande est le candidat le
plus apte à rassembler la gauche et donc
à défendre les couleurs de la gauche aux
prochaines élections présidentielles
merci et laisser une dernière partie de
l'épreuve de vérité maintenant avec
michaël szames s de public sénat
bonsoir michael bond sessions aux
ministres de l'économie et des finances
alors est ce que la droite a le remède
pour sauver l'économie française sur nos
croix françois fillon retraite à 65 ans
les 39 heures et si c'était la bonne
formule alors j'aurai une première
tendance de dire mais si ça avait été la
bonne formule ça se serait vu ça aurait
eu déjà donné des bons v sont pas allés
jusque là et et et c'est exactement ce
que je me dis c'est que ovo ils ne sont
pas allés jusque là aujourd'hui nous
avons une droite qui dit clairement ce
qu'elle veut faire du point de vue
économique et social les ce qu'elle
appelle des réformes
moi ce que j'appellerai les cassures
qu'elle soit la plus faible oui sont des
cassures parce que là je trouvais en
bois la réforme elle est indispensable
moi je suis un réformiste parce que je
sais très bien qu'on ne peut pas
protéger par exemple notre système
social
si on ne fait pas évoluer sur le
différencier des soir parfois certains à
gauche ou à ultra gauche qui disent faut
rien toucher fout rien bouger ça va se
tenir tout seul non ça ne tient pas tout
seul un système de sécurité sociale
santé de vieillesse pour le faire
évoluer au gré de l'évolution de
l'économie y était mais pas la cassure
quand les freins cette droite là elle
nous dit je vais faire et je me fiche
des corps intermédiaires et pire encore
des syndicats ça dépend quel candidat
s'il dudus tous très bien à juppé qui
est prêt à discuter notamment sur
l'application des ventes 9 heures au
terrain dans les branches et des
entreprises
j'ai pas tout bien compris parce que je
finis pas pu savoir quelles sont les
différences entre les uns et les autres
mais moi j'ai compris une chose j'ai
compris une chose quand j'écoute nicolas
sarkozy quand j'écoute françois fillon
quand j'écoute bon à l'affût d'un nombre
d'autres l'idée suivant laquelle il faut
faire en passant en force c'est une idée
qui les rassemble l'idée sûr il faut
faire en force faire en force moi c'est
pas ma vision des choses ne disent pas
ça exactement non ils disent et y en a
pas c'est de la dictature de la cgt on
entend ça attire des syndicats plutôt
voilà donc passer en force
ces sept s'étaient reportés par une
partie du monde
économique ou patronal ultralibérale qui
considère que la réforme le compromis
c'est perdre du temps tenons une société
elle ne se réforme pas en force
elle se casse quand on passe en force et
j'ai dit récemment alain juppé devrait
s'en souvenir
parce qu'il a voulu une fois passer en
force sur une réforme qui était
peut-être nécessaire par ailleurs et il
s'est cassé les dents
et s'il a fallu d'autres y compris nous
pourrons être en partie vous amène à
passer en force par rapport à l'ensemble
des pas des ambitions syndicales nous
met cela sur le travail vous êtes un
petit peu passer en force
si vous voulez dire essai en force et
49,3 milliards en prêts quand ce n'est
pas les élections syndicales sur les
déficits la droite et encore une fois
vous si vous me permettez ils disent que
si jamais ils reviennent au pouvoir ils
verront les résultats de votre budget et
les déficits
soro explosé mais comment peut-on dire
des déficits auront explosé personne ne
dit les déficits vont être plus élevé
que en 2002 faut juste enfin de rester
un tout petit peu sérieux donc 5% en
cette année 3 3% personne ne conteste
que nous atteindrons nos objectifs et
pour l'année prochaine même on peut
toujours contester la népalaise d'après
mais cette fois nous prenons nous
prenons tous les moyens détroit 2 7% et
en dessous des 3%
bon voilà c'est un chemin qui est un
chemin qui est raisonnable et tout d'un
coup vous avez la droite qui passe pour
être sérieuse et qui vous dire
maintenant moi je m'en fiche les
déficits les français éliront moi je me
suis peut-être du déficit mais derrière
le déficit y à quoi il faut financer ce
déficit
derrière le déficit il ya le l'emprunt
et de l'emprunt il faut bien le robot
pas raisonner en point mais c'est pas
ces mêmes passer cette qu'irresponsable
pas raisonnable ce serait presque faire
un compliment c'est totalement un haut
responsable à la droite qui nous a rien
aujourd'hui une droite qui porte un
projet économique avec ses conséquences
budgétaires qui veut paraître
irresponsable socialement parce que
c'est des cassures et des ruptures et
dans ces cas là la france elle se crispe
quand vous voulez passer en force
vous faites là le glorieux pendant
quelques mois
vous dites que j'y vais j'y vais je vais
aller à bruxelles je veux leur dire que
je fais comme ça je vais aller devant
les français je veux dire on y va en
force mais au bout de pas très longtemps
ça se crise ça se bloque et ya plus de
réformes
c'est pas comme ça qu'on peut faire
avancer la france mettant décision larry
responsable du social où s'exprimera si
je pars
la rue c'est la société qui se crispe
promettait l'enfer des gens qui se crise
mais c'est pas faux mais l'enfer c'est
pas nous qui déciderons ils ont connu
l'enfer quand ils ont voulu passer en
force sur un certain nombre de réformes
est par contre quand ils sont passés
dans le dialogue
je le dis pour des réformes de droite
comme pour les nôtres quand ils sont
passés dans le dialogue
il ya eu des réformes et des réformes
durables des réformes qui ne sont pas
remises en cause des réformes qui
produisent leurs effets donc c'est une
politique irresponsable socialement
parce que si une petite de cassures et
de rupture et si possible responsable du
point de vue des finances publiques
parce qu'alors relancer les déficits
aujourd'hui après tous les efforts qui
ont été demandés par les français et par
eux avant 2012 et par nous depuis 2012
franchement c'est un sacré gâchis après
le refus de la wallonie de ratifier
l'accord de libre échange entre l'europe
et le canada est ce que cet accord que
morts j'espère que non je pense que
c'est un accord qui ait un accord de
bonne qualité il faut l'expliquer parce
qu'il ya toujours un parieur il je pars
en plein temps mais c'est je pense c'est
un accord de qualité il faut qu'il soit
discuté suivant les règles quand ce
n'est pas moral de chacun des pays je
l'espère que j'espère que non ce serait
dommage qu'il soit mort parce qu'il
apporterait un mieux au français il
apporterait un mieux au français il sait
pas danger c'est tant mieux pour les
fraudeurs celui-là par la scpa l'autre
parce que celui là il est d'une
meilleure qualité il a été beaucoup
mieux négocier il a permis de respecter
à se rendre de choses des services
publics la culture l'environnement je ne
veux pas rentrer sur tous les détails
alors que celui qui est en cours de
négociation avec les états unis et d'une
autre qualité enfin publiquement il n'a
pas la même qualité d'agent de voir la
wallonie il a imposé sa loi à 500
millions d'européens
on sait les règles c'est des règles
constitutionnelles de chacun des pays je
ne vais pas les critiquer mais je pense
qu'il serait meilleur pour tout le monde
y compris pour la wallonie que cet
accord puisse être signé merci beaucoup
mais se soient plaints d'avoir été avec
nos sociétés mais qu'at elle pensera
tous a très vite on se retrouve dans 15
jours maintenant
à